hey guys Pete here this is going to be
much Q&A from the last three videos I
did on Twin Peaks season 3 part 6
we had the reaction video with the top
moments the scene-by-scene breakdown and
the recap and review and the 10 things
you might have missed video which the
title of that is pretty self-explanatory
so spoiler warning if you haven't
watched season 3 part 6 yet of the
return then you're going to want to stop
watching I got a ton of videos about all
the earlier episodes though so check
those out and let's jump right into it
so the first question was what's the
connection between call and the log lady
now I mentioned this and it is a secret
history of Twin Peaks thing and it's
sort of a book spoiler but it seems
pretty darn important so I guess yeah
what happened was is when they were kids
in 1940 the log lady who was named
Margaret Coulson before she had her
married name of Lanterman Col rod and
the third child were they disappeared
when they were out in the woods by twin
peaks they showed up the next day
unharmed but they had the same marking
like a tattoo with the triangles like
major breaks got and they didn't realize
they had been gone or what had happened
so much so if you know it was like an
abduction story but yeah that was added
into the secret history about Carl so
you know it kind of leads up to what he
says
I've already been places if I walk with
me that that's probably what he's
talking about
next question what's the story with
Diane well this question I guess is
referring to who Laura Dern's character
is and she was the FBI employee that
agent Cooper always talked to through
his tape recorder
remember he would say Diane it's this
Diana stat you know and he would
basically record his thoughts or
different things that happened and then
we assumed that he sent the tapes to
this person in the beginning we didn't
really know anything about her but if I
walk with me when they're at the
FBI headquarters she's off-screen like
he's talking to Diane we don't hear her
talk or whatever but there's no tape
recorder involved like she's actually
physically in the office it was never
sure whether she'd be real revealed or
not and that's why it's such an
interesting development next question
what do Dougie's drawings actually mean
this is in relation to what he was
putting on the documents and I don't
think we really know or should know what
they are some people have said that they
look like a ladder going up to the slope
of the roof with the tiles I don't
really know how that connects I mean
that could be the case I just don't
really see a clear connection to him
doing something at work related to what
was going on with the bumper of his car
on top of that woman's house but other
than that I think that it's just what
the the questioned person said you know
it shows that Anthony Sinclair or Tony
is involved in something that the boss
is concerned about next question is it
significant that sunny Jim's first words
were I already brushed my teeth well a
lot of people think it is because you
remember that whenever tube came out
with the bloody forehead you know he
they told to get in bed or whatnot and
he was you know I'm paraphrasing a bit
here but he said you know he hadn't
brushed his teeth yet he went into the
bathroom to brush his teeth and that's
where we first saw the reveal a bob so
yeah it could be connected to that but
there's no other conclusive evidence
we're gonna have to wait and see
like I said in other videos I think
there is something up with sonny jim but
i am not ready to jump on board on any
complete theory about that yet
next question maybe we are seeing the
slow awakening of dougie coupe from
inside his mind and I picked this one
because there's there was a lot of talk
about this and sort of about maybe the
whole dougie verse or you know where
dougie lived is is made-up or it's a
dream there is a possibility that that's
the case I mean i actually thought maybe
Janie ii and sonny jim were actors paid
by coop I mean there's a lot of things
but there's also real world stuff that's
coming in contact with this dream like
if we're to believe that the dream is so
complicated
that jade has seems by herself while she
mailed the key so that's going to show
up sooner or later or else why would it
be important I'm not saying you know
that's not conclusive evidence sure but
those are the things that make me wonder
if it's not just kind of what it seems
and that dougies taking so long because
that's the way that it was designed or
written you know so I don't know more
about dougie in a bit I guess this was
about the bathroom at the police station
the next question I wonder if there's
significance to it being the woman's
room and yeah we all comfy blasters
question and actually what happens is
his Hawk is in the men's room where the
paper is recovered but whenever Chad
comes in and starts bugging him he tells
him to use the ladies room and then he
said something else he says Chad use
another bathroom so yeah when I went
back and checked Hawk discovered the
notes or the pages whatever it is or
turns out to be in the men's room not
the ladies room next question is a
popular one that people write quite a
bit is it possible the meth mom is
saying one-one-nine because it's 9-1-1
backwards and yeah i think i touched on
this in another video at least i touched
on in the comments before that's pretty
much the most common gas as to what it
is now and I think the best evidence
that I've heard from it is someone who
says that they were a native French
speaker was watching episode 3 with the
subtitles on French subtitles and it
said 1 1 2 instead of 1 1 9 and in
France I guess I'm not from there
obviously the emergency number is 2 1 1
instead of 9 1 1 so that means that it's
probably likely that's why she's saying
it now a lot of people also jump to the
conclusion that that's Lodge related and
I see where that idea comes from but
really the only thing about the lodge
that we know is that when you hear other
people there they are the actors are
speaking backwards they learn their
lines backwards and then it is recorded
and then they play it backwards so it
comes out the right way but it has a
really weird effect so yeah they are
speaking backwards but it's a filming
technique more than it's a
set like everything happens backwards in
the lodge in my my interpretation and it
could be completely wrong but yeah it
could be it could be a nod to that I
mean there's obviously something going
on with this lady but we don't really
know what it is next question how long
is this dougie coupe thing going to last
well it has been stretching out over a
few episodes at this time but agent
Cooper's only been in Dougie's life for
less than whatever 24 hours are a little
bit over 24 hours so it hasn't actually
been going that long time wise and like
I said I touched on it before earlier I
think that this is supposed to be I
think this characters supposed to
develop this way I find that it's a
little bit frustrating at times but I
don't I don't get bothered by it as much
as some people and then I don't love it
as much as other people I see talking
about it so it's just one of those
things there's a lot of other stuff
going on it's I think it's just there's
a lot of attention to it because people
want Cooper to be the way he used to be
and we really don't know how that's
going to develop I think that Diane is
probably the key to that but they're
still quite some distance in between
when she's going to meet up with coop so
who knows you know and maybe there's
going to be a significant amount of
episodes where she has to be the Cooper
of this season you know maybe maybe Dale
Cooper isn't going to be the same as he
was in the first two seasons next
question how did evil coop manufacture
the original dougie Jones well that
can't really be answered because we
don't know that he did we know that he
created something to switch out with
himself you know so he wouldn't get
sucked back into the lodge what we don't
know is how dougie coop has this life
it's one of two things I guess right
either this guy existed and coop did
some sort of spell and replaced a living
person with someone that looked like him
that could be sucked into the lodge or
the whole thing is manufactured but
neither one of those is easy to prove
that it's the one that's happening and
like I said I I think that there's some
sort of magic involved magic with a K
because there was so much talk of that
sort of thing with Jack Parsons and
Hubbard and you know them trying to do
Aleister Crowley stuff in the secret
history so more of that may be revealed
or maybe it won't maybe it'll actually
be revealed in the next book whenever it
comes out the final dossier has anyone
else noticed the symbol on the
drugged-out mom's house changes from
episode three five and six
it's the next question and I went my
volt and I see what you're talking about
but I think it might be light if you
look at all three of them it's the same
basic shape it just seems like you can
see parts of it depending on how the
light is so I don't think it is let me
know what you guys think next question
are the electricity sounds we hear after
the car accident the same as the one the
giant plays now I played a bunch of
these and looked at these closer I think
there's two distinct sounds the ones
that the giant plays and then the ones
that play in relation to the electricity
and the car crash and everything else
now I mentioned before I first noticed
this sound that we hear by the telephone
pole and electrical lines when the arms
doppelganger is introduced in part two
so I think that most of that is related
to the arms doppelganger but I'm not
saying that that's what it is for sure
we still need to find out next question
do you think we will find out what
happened to chat Desmond I've answered
this before but I'll answer to gain him
and my thoughts are his chat Desmond's
character was written out of the story
he was written into the story late to
replace agent Cooper who you know Kyle
MacLachlan didn't want to take a large
role in fire walk with me so they just
sort of added chat Desmond in most of
this is based on the fact that we know
Chris Isaak's isn't coming back and then
the guy who was standing with him
outside of the bus who was not not even
didn't have a speaking part really is is
listed in the cast of characters come
back so I could be wrong but I don't
think he'll be important going forward
and the last question when will they
finally introduce Audrey and big head
and doc Hayward well I would say once we
get the story focused more on zan heat I
mean obviously Audrey could come into
the story whenever the
arrives at the Great Northern or some
other way big Edie
this is another secret history spoiler I
guess big Edie is still married to
Nadine we've seen Nadine so he can't be
too far away and we do know the doc
Hayward saw shot scenes but we don't
know what role he's going to play
because there's no talk of Donna
returning or his wife so that's really
all that we know all right thanks so
much for asking all the questions I
enjoy that I really enjoy chatting with
you guys in the comments if you haven't
checked out the other videos from this
episode please do so please like the
video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel because more Twin Peaks
videos will be coming next week thanks
for watching I'll talk to you soon